私はあの日をもってしまった
クラッカーを水の中で打ち込むとどうなるのか
クラウドは中に入って軽い感じでポンディベート部位かクズとか力を持っているやつ5
分中で倶楽部カー落ち込んだらどうなんだろうか
頑張って
えっ少し
オサレである今ご覧になって頂いだと思うんですけど俺がやった時は pot 取得朝
ガラスのコップがもぶっ飛んでクラシックだったんですけどもうなぁ今行った時はもう
なんかここに水かかるくらいすごい水がはねちゃということで
フラップター水牢な箇所するとものすごいバザーズ力があるが僕は気づいてしまう立っ
て冷静に考えてみると中にあの細いロールテープが入ってるわけ
ですからねカレーねただの紙ペラをあんだけトートに泊まってことは2鯉力が入ってる
ってことで深く気づきました
ええええええええええ
ええええええ
というわけであんまり皆やってないと思うんですけどちょっとこんないくらかを水の中
に打ち込むとどうなるのかその継承していきたいと思いますよいつものはこちらは普通
のクラッカー金日ながらクラッカー
これだが2名するかなり力が強いみたいですこういったやべるぞはいこちら
big クラッカーですこれもやばいんじゃないですかねかなり力が強そうで次が
こちらです
予想以上に大きい区
あっかこれは中で投げてちゃったんですけどまだ残ってるんですよねなんで中身だけで
たんだろうコレなにか載せたら布団でしょ
こんなもんでしょうねこちらの装いずに音がいくらカボチャの期待でございます最後は
こちらで迫力最高と書いてありますで見てなんて多分一番強いであろうクラッカーで
ございます
どういうで今回こちらのどちらか1つを気遣って水中で打ち込むとクラッカーどんな月
よどっちとみなすて分かってもらうと思います
いやをやった時はねもうね本当に下落コップ
ん
見やすい今日まあ
ウォーター
ます
コップでやりましょうちょっと水が強すぎるねちょっと桜肉ラフかあさんもちょっと
厳しそうな顔してました
じゃああたって水2不安ウォーター
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
もっと強くなかった毛先に入っ
めちゃくちゃ微妙マン誰かがもうばれ食らったってや本などここからこれはもう意欲が
格段に違うと思いますすみます
あーはっはっは
カメラ俺コレコレコレですよ
同じが夫の保管品で御座いませんいきます凄い恋来はそのセンサーヤバイぞ
いきます
んいます
th
はぁ
[音楽]
はぁもうちょっと怖くて行うと降ってきては何が起こった今
耳いたチームを引っ張っていきますツリー
[音楽]
どこが一番ひどい買った俺の足元で地味にすごいなこれほ一発いきましょう
いきます
[音楽]
妻がこちらのなんか強さ目大トリですこれから食べ最強級レベルでいきますその時
はじめは思ったこれ何に使うんだろう zimmer
はぁ
ぽぽぽぽーんあなた一番弱いよたっを直で的なさん
お前
me
ええええええ
あっあっ